um hello hi oh cool so everyone
understands English everyone signs my
version of English right you all own
that you all hear the voices in my head
not all of them be glad some of them are
my children at one o'clock in the
morning going papa egg Villa Havana and
I was getting up at 5:30 to go on a
flight and I was like okay apparently
that my children are only its will only
accept me giving them water otherwise if
my wife goes in they will kick up a
storm which my wife exploits maliciously
on me going get out of it go fix the
children okay so this is hacking your
neighbor and other life skills today I'm
going to show you how to break all the
things and I am bound by law to give you
disclaimer
don't do this against your neighbors
even though the title says - don't do
this against your neighbors because you
will end up like bad neighbors you will
end up like my neighbors who are
wondering why their Wi-Fi doesn't work
they're wondering why they're getting
charges on their Amazon car our gift
cards they're wondering why they're
getting deliveries from strange things
at 4 o'clock in the morning usually me
going will you turn off the music and I
joke a little bit because the the reason
this talk evolved was purely from an
instant that happens so I was setting up
a Wi-Fi pineapple we've all seen this
device it's a rogue access point and I
was setting this up I was getting ready
for I think it is possibly a security
day about two years ago here and I was
getting all my gear and in doing
regional prep and I leave this thing in
my living room and I go out to collect
my kids from kindergarten and I come
back and I'm wondering I wonder how far
the reach of this thing is so I'm
sitting outside in our garage and I'm
like I can still see this I start seeing
all the different Wi-Fi points kicking
up and it's like in their alphabetic and
I was like ah that's new it's the name
of my neighbor and a number ha I wonder
is that his Wi-Fi password I was like
let me check it is his Wi-Fi password I
was like this is awesome so this is how
hacking your neighbor's got came as an
evolution so if you've never met me
before my name is Niall I am the head of
cyber security at Capgemini here in
Norway
yes we're hiring I do want to recruit
all cool people and I want to get all
mad people to work with me because it
makes me funner I am a most valuable
professional from an MVP for Microsoft
specifically in dev SEC I'm an ASP
insider advisor tweet me because I do
answer tweets emails not so much much to
the chagrin of my boss and you can visit
our website or if you're really really
masochistic and don't like yourself go
to my website now this is talk about
hacking and people generally ask me why
on earth do you want to teach people how
to hack other people and I have one
answer for this and it's this particular
quote you can only fight the way you
practice ie how many of you have learned
to drive hands up if you can't drive ok
I can't really see if I'm assuming no
one put up their hands but you know when
you learn to drive you didn't get in a
simulator did you know you got in the in
a car white-knuckled sweat dripping down
your back and someone said drive and you
went ok
and you went you literally kept gripping
the steering wheel as hard as possible
but you got through it now imagine doing
that the simulator been told after you
pass your exam now go out and drive
another crazy people now I learned to
drive you driving a motorbike for the
first time now when I was told about
this I said like the instructor goes he
says right Niall
gratulations you've got a bike do you
have an organ donor card and I said why
he goes because you just became one I
said on a very fast machine and it's
like okay good choice man good talk and
then he says no it's like driving a car
with this a 2 meter spiked relatively
this close to your body
and if you make a mistake you dead
alright so that is why I when I learned
to drive a car I was exceptionally
defensive I was watching everyone I said
you're all crazy I'm gonna kill you all
before you kill me right boss I learned
to drive on a road like everyone else
and if you're a boxer you box against
the bag to train to get fish but you box
against an opponent to learn what it
looks like and what it feels like a to
get hit and how to anticipate your
opponent's moves it's the same thing
with hacking techniques if you don't
understand how the hack works you will
never know how to
defend against it it's like the idea of
when most of us get alarms in houses we
get them after we've broken into for
example my parents we live in the back
hours of nowhere in Ireland there is 500
metres between any of our neighbours
it's fantastic it's lovely it's like
Norwegian ideal living conditions you
know Hitler but except with toilets that
work now the thing is I'm there and I'm
like going we came home one day and we
found a block in the bathroom it's not
meant to be there there's broken glass
and we go around we find two computers
missing we find everything missing my
parents first initial reaction was we're
buying an alarm and I went how is that
gonna help we're 500 meters from anybody
what's gonna happen they'll hear this
thing on oh that's nice
and then it's gonna come to your aid she
goes well it'll make me feel safe and I
said okay so this is the idea why if
they understood the attack first they
might have done something beforehand but
because they still don't understand the
attack or why someone did it they're not
they're just applying defensive measures
it's the same thing like we do inside in
Airlines we now have to go through
scanners we now have to take off our
shoes we have to take away all the
liquids these are all reactionary things
that have been done based on someone
going I wonder if they check for that do
you know how to beat most airline kind
of systems use extra two or three things
extra and they won't notice
so just shove like if you got more than
100 millimetres of fluid put an extra
bag somewhere over here and they
probably don't see it it'll go through
because they're only checking for that
if you've got more than that bag they
don't see it they won't do it and that's
the hacking it's also how to hack for
example a how to get lounge access at an
airport sure how to get lounge access an
airport seriously okay so you have the
person which got their ticket they go
into the lounge
the next person wouldn't ask them
they're automatically granted because
they're the guest the other one so just
wait they're not suspicious at all in
there force off you go so that's that's
just a joke but I kind of this was a I
talked I saw once before where a guy
showed me how to do it with QR codes and
where people put up their QR codes on
Twitter and you just go searching for
people who have been there use that QR
code then to get into a lounge it's not
a great way to travel
just saying
what I'm going to show you today is a
lot of things like strategy how we do
the Recon how we find information about
our attacks how we go looking for
vulnerabilities how we exploit said
vulnerabilities and also kind of some
social engineering and other advanced
techniques that I'd like to show off
because it's a lot of fun and also I
thought this is a great picture of a cat
reading military strategy which is
literally how I see most cats in general
when they look at people
you're just a larger meal to them and I
have a cat and she's lovely but ah yeah
I do say this seriously please don't do
this at home please don't do this
against systems you don't know please
don't do this against people you like
please don't do this against people you
don't like it's a very broad scenario
but the thing is a lot of the tools I'm
going to show you today have offensive
capabilities in other words they are
designed to break into stuff and people
don't like stuff being broken into
because people like to feel safe and I
don't take that away from them but I
want you to understand that for every
single tool I'm going to show you
there's a defense against it but they're
usually just doing a single exploit but
please for the love of God and for the
love of like staying out of Norwegian
cells and things that don't do this at
home now with that in mind here's that
lets me show you how to get arrested
this is kali linux kali is a debian
based distro linux distro built from the
ground up with the load of security
tools involved anyone used carly already
today cool so everyone's gonna have know
what that is that's awesome if you don't
go download the torrent file it's one of
the few legit reasons to use a torrent
client and you can install this and put
it on vmware box and do mad things with
it but some of the stuff I'm going to
show you today specifically involve some
of these specific tools which is like
the N map which is are sorry which is
the N my project or n map which is a
network mapping protocol it's one of the
best reconnaissance tools out there so
how many of you kind of when you go to a
Wi-Fi network or anything that snoop and
check who else is on the network with
you Aaron stop that by the way how's
your country they all good so there's a
running joke back in in 2013 a go to con
in our house Aaron and presenta just
before me and the country had shut down
I think just that morning and we're here
again presenting and we were faced with
a similar thing who
since I think not we're not allowed in
the same country anymore it's ours I can
understand now with with network mapper
we do this a lot where you will actually
scan and see what other network are
other people are on the network with you
you might find some interesting devices
like printers point of sale devices Hart
machines other things like that it's a
very interesting thing to do not I don't
recommend doing it at hospitals people
get a bit obsessed when my brother was
in the ICU the intensive care unit I was
sitting in the waiting room waiting and
the first thing I do is I flick up my
phone and see what Wi-Fi is available I
see Hospital hospital Drager homes at
heart starter and rhaegar ventilation
machine and I'm thinking better not
connect to those you can imagine very
I'm playing a downloading imager while
someone's trying to get breath out of
them it's not going to work but never if
mapper is very good for finding things
there's an some open-source tools I'm
going to show you today as well which
are very very cool for finding things
Metasploit which is the granddaddy of
exploitation tools it allows you to
without having to know a lot of
difficult commands it weaponized us all
the vulnerabilities for you and it
allows you to exploit them remotely or
locally whatever and finally I'm going
to show you thing called beef now beef
is one of my favorite little projects
because besides having an absolutely
cool name it is a really interesting way
of why you should be using HTTPS and why
if you get hacked or websites get hacked
what you can do with more advanced XSS
than your vanilla alert one now again
public service announcement number two
don't do this okay without a get out of
jail free card if you are a professional
pen tester one of the things you always
ask for is a scope of engagement and the
second thing you ask for is can I get a
get-out-of-jail-free card
ie if I break your system so badly that
you doomed you dead you don't come after
me with all the fullest extent to the
law it's literally the thing that says
get out of jail free you get these cards
they're very handy but I will recommend
that you kind of go look at this in a
controlled environment set up a couple
of VMs on the cloud or locally and go
play with all the tools I'm going to
show you today it's a lot of fun it does
kind of get you from the I know nothing
- holy crap my neighbors are doomed or
okay so with that in mind let's start
with some reconnaissance and we learn
firstly how we're going to find where
information lives and the first thing I
know I want to talk to you about is what
is known as a CV e are common
vulnerabilities and exposures now what
this is is a method for a centralized
method for people to put together a list
of all the vulnerabilities on products
but also to get a nice number on it so
you can be assured that everyone's were
counting off the same kind of book and
for me it's a real good way to find out
what's wrong in the world because when
people publish CVS they tell you what's
wrong it's great so you learn about
vulnerabilities so how many of you patch
regularly yeah how many of you know what
ii choose in every month is has choose
it great what's the second lens in every
month roll back Wednesday it didn't work
or you know every system administrator
is a month out of date stick if you're a
SharePoint administer you're six months
out of date because no one wants to try
and fix SharePoint I can tell you that
much they've tried hard number versions
now the thing here is that they get you
get different CVS scores based or cbss
scores based on how bad it is and nine
to ten is bad very very very very bad so
I went looking for what what is bad and
I said okay let's go look at what the
latest one is the latest like number
nine is from Cisco WebEx network or
importing player for brands la blah blah
it allows a remote code execution now do
you know what remote code execution is
excellent jackpot
it's because you're there you go exploit
and it goes boom another person goes
what just happened and you own the
machine you don't have to do anything
you can be anywhere in the world someone
can do things and you remotely execute
code really cool but we also find things
like for example command injection OS
command injection remote code injection
authenticated shell command injection
you kind of see a pattern with this
command injection is bad I'm Kai so when
people are that's not the Canadians so
this is where we tell people keep an eye
on this on a day to day basis there is a
Twitter feed that does this to show you
all this kind of information
if you have products you use on a
day-to-day basis go in here and check it
if you have an Asus Rooter throw it out
the window if you have a tp-link router
throw it out the window
d-link router throw it out the window
Nikki Rooter yeah throw it out the
window
so all of these things have very bad
vulnerabilities usually remote code exec
and other things which it means that
people can go find them you can go and
get information about a bit more as well
from NIST which gives you more kind
things I just went looking for sequel I
sequel injection was coined in 1998
Rytas 20 years ago in internet terms
it's it should be dead you know it's
it's it's old it's it's allowed to die
now it's unlife support but people keep
bringing it back and making it better
it's like it's ridiculous it's like
Donald Trump just being reborn or
evaluated and I don't know what it is
but seriously this is still going on and
you can see like the last number is
twenty seventeen fifty five eighty 1587
the funny thing is they're numbered from
2017 the Year number then a four digit
number and going up and the as I'm as I
understand I think 80% of them are flash
vulnerabilities from 2017 and the rest
are Java or something that but in
general most things in there are flash
and that's why it's dying in 2019 we've
only got one year left as hackers to
really exploit us thanks anyway if you
want to go find out how to exploit the
things you go to the exploit database
aptly named because where else would you
find things in the next database and
they have things like remote exploit web
application exploits I loaded this today
and it tells me that secret injection is
still a thing again as you can see and
it's all in PHP now I always made the
joke and I intended a couple of people
by saying what does PHP stand for
yeah you've got the real thing I call a
pretty horrible programming but it's do
you know why there's so many secret
injection attacks in PHP it's not
because PHP is a crap language in fact
it's a very good language why is there
so many attacks in PHP because there's
such a low barrier to entry it's a lamp
stack you've fired up everything works
it's all free cool it can run on
absolutely anything and then people go
to things like the code project and says
give me a command string that will
connect to a database
boom yay and then they go off and sell a
wordpress plugin all right and then
something goes oh you've made the same
mistake wink and that's how you make
money from bug bounties when people make
stupid mistakes and you recognize the
stupid mistake you automate to find it
and then make bug money from the bug
bounty so if you want to go and say well
you know this looks hard now and I only
know how to use the internet like for
Google we do have a thing called a
Google hacking database which is pretty
awesome and this is a list of Google
dorks that can get you to find different
information around the web which Google
is very good at finding now I do
highlight the one that says files
containing passwords because you know we
all like to think that it's hard we have
to go off and crack a password we have
to kind of go brute force it wouldn't be
just easier if I could just google it so
we can and if you go googling is
specifically something like this where I
go in information blah blah blah but I
always the one I'd like to show is the
kind of the anyone whose a.net developer
here asp.net great you know web.config
great what can't you do with web config
well you can't access it over here over
is over HTTP right face - yes but you
can't access it over FTP no problem and
people leave that open
so you just google it I love this one
here we go and it's just you can go
download it if you want there's no
problem and they're probably stuff
inside there though that said I did
notice if you do try and google this
Google goes I think you're up to no good
are you sure you're not a robot sure it
says don't be evil sure why not uh if
you wanna learn how to do XSS there's a
really good one here called the open bug
bounty which is a group of pen testers
who are looking very specifically how to
do XSS attacks and they put up how they
found them and it's still very very
common you can see here like how like
Amazon Linkedin etc all have been poned
at some point with XSS attacks and they
do kind of report these things Troy
showed this morning how do you showdown
and he said well you can find boring
stuff in it like IAS 6 I found is 6 and
I quite liked it because is 6 is running
on what version of Windows 2003 what's
what 2003 its end of life which makes
this lots of fun you know you've over
half and
million targets I mean potentially
vulnerable machines I'm trying to get
you into the hacker mindset like this is
how I look at the world my mother once
said you're very paranoid and I said if
you look at the world the way I did you
would be too but I also decided to go
what' though yes
so we also talked about like don't even
catch Felix's talk yet just half before
mine he talked about eternal blue in SMB
Samba so that's the kind of access
backslash walk back UNC paths now if you
want to go looking for UNC paths that
are open for people to play with and
download from files
this is 883 thousands SMB servers
worldwide that you can connect to
without any single version of
authentication now if you're wondering
what the username and password for this
is its most likely guest and blank or if
there's a password at all now the thing
is you go looking for things like this
and you will find Time Machine backups
you will find photo directories you will
find corporate information and you can
scan this and download it and no one
will know you've been there because you
love u2 VPN right because you know your
IP is tied to you so don't do that
so use a VPN anyway everybody um I have
a very interesting thing today and I
guess it's because I've been looking
forward to this since this morning
you know Amazon s3 great do you know
what they're great at got a thing called
a bucket everyone sound a bucket is it's
a great place to find information now
I'm very lucky and we're very we are
very lucky today
that a gentleman has written a piece of
software that I can steal and he put it
on github and he wrote this thing called
bucket stream bucket stream uses two
very cool techniques one is called a
certificate transparency log if you
haven't seen Scott Helens talk at NDC
London or he's I think you might be
doing today certificate transparency
logs show you when people average sir
certificate and by using that instead of
brute-forcing
s3 bucket names we are just getting what
people are registering and then trying
to find stuff now the person in question
is written this actually exists in the
real world is sitting here
David Prince can you get up and take her
around applause take a sign up
hello so if you want to complain about
someone's code he's right here
you know you can do it in person and
that means you have to be nice code what
Oh code bill right now what does this
look like in real terms it's running
right now and what have we found today
this these are all like who unify
staging that could be interesting now
what's cool is we're finding different
s3 buckets wait that are open or have
now the ACS might not all be open but
some of them are and a lot of cases they
are completely open and readable and
writeable so if you ever need some
storage that's where you put it but also
it just shows you how easy it is to find
these things because on the internet
everyone knows you're a cat
now you can find things like God knows
likes convergence dev and convergence
prod for example follow the very
standard issue of well we have a dev
version and we have a proud version you
can probably kind of guess they probably
have conversions - stage of convergence
- test or - UAT because you know all
developers have three three things so
this is a very easy way to find things
again also a very easy way to find
information that people have been
displaying or putting out accidentally
online DoD got done with an open s3
buckets and found a whole lot of
contractor data you can find sequel
boxes you can find sequel backups config
files JSON files whatever it's
ridiculous what people are putting in
these things and is even more ridiculous
that are not securing so if you have an
s3 bucket close it and otherwise people
like me will be scanning this I'm gonna
try and extend his excellent work and
try and scale it much much wider so we
can start kind of doing a hall-of-fame
of open buckets which i think would be
kind of cool anyway so that is a
guidance on how to do kind of tooling on
the web and just use a browser to find
your way around what I'm going to show
you now is that was the s3 buckets thing
from last night let's get that but I
what I'm gonna show you now is how to do
Wi-Fi attacking and this is specifically
to do recon around when you're in a
location you don't know what's happening
so what I'm gonna show you now is the
thing called Ehrmann and what I'm gonna
do is use a device like this little here
this $20 adapter and I'm gonna set it
into monitor mode another is promiscuous
it's just listening to all the traffic
going back and forth so I can see what's
happening so if I do airodump-ng and I
just tell it to go to wlan0 man
in other words I'm telling it go use the
monitor it'll tell me all the Wi-Fi
networks that are around me right now
and you can see my my home network is
called silliest name my wife and I've a
silly a guest
I can also Farsi like for example my
neighbor upstairs I can see the couple
of ulti boxes that are round and it
doesn't really tell me a lot but it does
tell me what devices are looking what
access points are available
yeah I could do better and I get more
information by running a different
command which is gonna be interesting
because you can see like what station is
going down here so I'm gonna just clear
the screen and I'm gonna run tactic WPS
tech tech manufacturer and I'm gonna see
which one have WB wireless protected
setup and what type of device they're
running so you can see my home network
is running a Ubiquiti Networks a unified
networks my guest net results are
running on that but it's not telling you
that and I can don't know what the LT
boxes are running but most likely
they're running Motorola's just by the
name and after a little second I'll find
there's a thing called a drizzle I never
can pronounce that and it'll come up as
an Apple device so this is an Apple
Rooter user extreme or a time capsule or
something like now I imagine you found
there's a whole hidden SSID thing right
and you can't find it
the easiest way to find it is go looking
for all the different things that are
there all right you'll find the hidden
SSID and it'll have a bssid right so
what you do is you look for all the
devices are connected to that you just
listen for things that connect it back
and forth to that and then you do them
you knock them off the network it's a
very simple send a packet to the router
D off this device and it goes ok right
it's very nice it deals the device what
will the device now do it'll reconnect
and what will it do it will send out the
probe of what is looking for and now you
have the Wi-Fi name so we've ever trying
to find your hidden SSID that's how you
do it you can also do things like for
example do two people off a device if
you're near field you can then go say
okay I know you've an Apple device so
what you do is you do the Apple device
you tell us don't let anyone connect and
you stand up a fake access point with
the exact same name that's open you put
up a landing page that says welcome to
your Apple time port capsule extreme XYZ
and please put in your SSID name the
we need to update put in your SSID name
put in your administrator username and
password and also put in the white WPA
PA to SPR PSK file you are key you want
to use and people okay - did you - do
you give it about two minutes looks like
it's doing something and then you take
down the access point you stand there as
backup they're going cool my Rooter
updated that didn't lose any of my
settings and now you've accessed their
Wi-Fi password very quickly and
effectively by just doing some recon
right now I talked about nmap and one
things would end up is it's really hard
it was definitely written by engineers
so they have a ton of command line
switches for us so I like using Zen map
which tells me how to do things because
I'm simple and Irish and I go tell I
want to scan the entire subnet of my
virtual network to find out what's there
and to the magic of video editing
because this normally takes about four
minutes I just get all the information I
need
so you'll see about five computers
eventually popping up on the left-hand
side maybe even six so this shows me my
Rooter my gateway and it also shows me a
this is my particular gate weights on my
VM box it'll then if I go to the host
details it's kinda nice open windows
because windows are effectively
vulnerable honest and what it shows me
is like what version it thinks it is and
the different open ports but if I go to
128 which is a Metasploit able box this
is a purposely built vulnerable machine
for you to play with it shows me that
I'm running port v SFTP D 2.3.4 alright
I want you to remember that okay because
I know that version of V SFTP D is
vulnerable because I've done my recon I
what I would normally do is say okay
here's the ports you're running I've
gone into the open I've got the exploit
EB Ubuntu CVE details I've checked for
oh you have this and you have this
version there's a CVE score against it
and it's quite bad so now I can go
looking for exploits to against that
particular machine and to do that I'm
going to use a technique our tool called
Metasploit now Metasploit is really
awesome because it literally takes you
from zero to hacker in about three three
three keystrokes very easy but what is
for me what makes it it just shows you
how quick you can go from I know nothing
to having done a bit of recon to now
being able to get
shell or an exploit on a machine so if
we would do this here you just do MSF
console in Kali and it takes a little
bit of time to log just fire up a quick
shortcut is start the Postgres service
first and if you do that it'll cut down
the time I always look at like doing one
of my little things I like to go find
that the cow banner so you just keep
trying banner until you find the little
cow and I've kind of found him cuz he's
cute and what you can do that is type
help and you can get some commands now
we can link this back up to the Zen map
or the end map database so I'll have all
the list of hosts I've already found and
I'm now going to use that database
together but that's a bit more
complicated so I'm not going to do that
but I'm going to use an exploit UNIX FTP
d vs FTP T 2 3 4 backdoor all right if I
do info it says this backdoor was
introduced into the blah blah between
June 30th 2011 and July 1st 2011 so he
had 3 days according to the most recent
information Vil the backdoor was removed
on July 3rd 2011 so there was a
particular malicious backdoor introduced
into open source software oh wow
so I'm gonna set the remote host the
host I want to tak a to attack very
complicated I just have to go and copy
the IP address in alright set the remote
host now what a new is type exploit
hacking done I now have root shell on
the machine if I do the following
command which i think is who am i here
we go
I'm ruse yay and you name - eh tells me
what machine I'm running on it's Linux -
thought about that a lot so I have root
on your machine is that bad dad yeah
it's ok you have very high standards I'm
good to see your talk let's say I have
root I would consider that ok III have
low threshold for awesomeness so root is
good now when I show this to people they
go that's nice
it's nice where's your where's your
hoody where's your massive amount of
typing where's your like really intense
like CSI effect nice is fine let me show
you that and this is what is this called
again
Armitage so Armitage has a very similar
nice UI so I'm gonna do the exact same
thing I'm going to instead of having to
do all the scanning at first I'm going
to integrate this together and go tell
it to go scan some information for me
and it's just again through the magic of
video editing once and I learns how the
type okay it brings up a nice set of
machines for me did I know I can hack so
this makes it a little bit easier right
cuz you know now I understand what I'm
doing
and what I can do now is I can go
scanning for vulnerabilities in the
application or in the in the US so I can
do this thing here and says great right
click I can do scan you know because I'm
I'm a hardcore hacker and I go find
attacks because I'm a lazy hacker now by
the way being lazy is not a bad thing in
programming we call it automation now
you know when you'd have to do things
twice so it says happy hunting I
right-click it goes attacks I go to FTP
I go down to the W SFTP d backdoor click
it fills in all the details I need to
know I click Launch I wait a couple of
seconds red lightning come on yeah that
means it's hacked alright now I can
interact with this because you know the
other thing was command-line that's what
you do want to train to freak the living
bejesus out of people this is what you
do at home but when you're trying to
learn how to do things okay by the way
have you ever ran hacker typer on like a
train ever know what you know what
hacker typer is go to have a curt I for
net go nuts I just do it on a train and
every so often do this with this thing
the giant aerial and watch people freak
out especially if you've got a little
black hoodie and just flick it up and go
and then furtively look over at
something going I can see what you're
doing now that is how you do
exploitation this is how you would find
like literally going from recon
I now know what's on the network to
going looking at CVE databases and then
going from there to find other
information
I always show people the hard way using
Zen map and CV search and Metasploit
together and then I show you the easy
way because then you understand how
simple it really is but also how much
work they've tied up to make it easier
for you because this is the life lesson
ladies and gentlemen how many of you are
married ok how many of you are like I I
my wife has a thing called husband
points everyone heard of husband points
husband points are amazing husband
points are things you can use when
you've screwed up bad they literally are
get-out-of-jail-free cards and they're
like literally like spending points on
like err ponens points and airplanes so
if you have if you really screwed up bad
you couldn't have to give 40 bonus
points or something so we have husband
points it's a joke we run between us
because I when I come and I just go I
just bought this it cost us ten thousand
kronor she goes what would you didn't
think to ask me first
how many husband points are we looking
at she was at least three glasses of
wine dawn right okay so I rock up and I
come in and I go honey
the photos disc is dead what the photos
disc is dead
mean dead I says it's dead it's in there
clicking it's like a dead cockroach it's
good and she's going what does that mean
is that all the photos are gone all the
photos I said all the photos which was
yes today before us yes the wedding
photos yes now the World Tour photos yes
Jesus Niall what are we gonna do just
put in a new disc why didn't you start
with that I said very simply you
wouldn't know how awesome I was but I
didn't if I just came in said I fixed
the photos this would you life lesson
never give away a chance to prove how
awesome you are
I said to be life skills in this right
you might learn hacking but this is also
human hacking so this is a thing but
please don't don't do it to ruin your
marriage it's not a good thing I don't
like the legal fees anyway so this is
beef this is a 48 ounce steak or what my
butcher sent up to me from Ireland
because it costs the same as
finger in Norway and the same piece of
beef and I looked at I love staring at
this photo this is my life
accomplishment I wish to have to survive
eating this now I love how they just
have a sprig of rosemary on the side
there's nothing else requires so beef a
stands for the browser exploitation
framework it is a single javascript file
that you can inject into websites and by
doing so take control of machines and to
have a lot of funds with people's now I
like to do this one because here's the
demo it's very simple we login using
beef and beef because this is a demo and
what's really kind of cool about this is
I can just it gives you a nice simple
overview of what's happening there is
very little on screen right now I can
see I've had some previously hooked
browsers because we use a lure in other
words something to catch people and then
we use a hook jus to catch you so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to switch
over to my Windows 10 machine and I'm
going to go to the particular URL that I
want that has the JavaScript injection
it's a butcher's website you don't where
you buy beef and it looks very
standard-issue nothing scary about it
whatsoever you'll see on the left hand
side the little icon will shift into
online meaning I now have a connection
to you so I've now got a connection back
to that particular browser by clicking
on us I can get information about the
browser I can see that you're running
for example ie 11 because you don't like
yourself you're running Windows 10 you
have Shockwave Flash installed for some
reason and you have a couple of other
different things here and it's a hooked
page is the butcher it has no page refer
but now I can also use different
exploits and you can see things like
social engineering because social
engineering is a lot of fun is you get
to play with people's heads and we're
gonna send Clippy to the browser because
who doesn't like Clippy she looked with
fire right
if I click execute I'm what we're going
to do is we go say thanks for upgrading
your browser look forward to having you
know the web so we're going to ask them
to upgrade their browser because ie 11
is the best browser for downloading
another browser now Clippy it turned up
now who wouldn't click on that imagine
Clippy turning up on your desktop and
you could send it a particular like new
flash update you can do different things
like one of the ones
I think this is really handy but this
when I show this off people are going
why do you use Clippy because the first
thing you wanna do is click to get rid
of little bastard
No so you know so what about things like
using petty theft and grabbing people's
Facebook accounts because everyone likes
using booger-face and we just click
execute and we have a nice website here
and in a couple of seconds boom would
you put in your username and password
here no not if it was my website but if
you're not expecting this people will
put information here quite willy-nilly
no problem and I just have Niles
password click login it goes away
awesome I've done something right use
nearly passwords rock still anyway and I
get the information back when I go and
click on the command I can see that
Niles password has appeared ok
eventually come on man you can do this
did I put in a lot more supposes in this
there is G's stuff this is why you
should record the videos as if you're a
lunatic and you can see here I can put
in the password I get the information
back it's very very simple I just did a
quick injection do things now the worst
part is I can automate all this I'm just
showing it because I wanted to show you
what you can do
like the fake notification bar this is a
kind of a throwback to the old stuff
remember we used to have say this page
wants to run a particular ActiveX
components for example so the one I'm
going to send is this website wants to
run the Java plug-in by Microsoft so
because you know who wouldn't and it
just did what the problem is on such a
large screen it's very hard to see it it
just this thing just drops underneath
the butt toolbar it kind of appears no
one will really notice it but it's one
of those things that I think that you
know don't it's kind of interesting
because you can you can get people to do
stuff and they'll inject stuff then
they'll click on links and they'll
download you can also detect if you've
got LastPass or flash and get them to
put in a new LastPass or flash update
here what I'm going to do here is I'm
gonna do tab napping so tab napping what
it does is how many of you use Chrome or
any a former browser and you have 8080
tabs open you don't know what so
anything is going on yeah and there's
music going on up in one place you don't
know where it is this what this idea is
it takes advantage of if I go back a
little bit I'll show you what has
happened sorry come back come on back
we'll go back to tab nothing so what tab
napping does is it takes advantage of if
your tab has been asleep for a while
then we're gonna change what's in the
tab so when you come back to us oh do
something so here what we're gonna do is
redirect you to go to Gmail alright now
this is the old Gmail logon but it
automatically what will happen is you
see in a second either so flick there we
go and it'll appear like this and you'll
think oh I've got something or better
log back in I've been logged logged out
so I'm just putting in some random
information and what's really cool is it
redirects you back to the actual correct
login because I haven't been logged in
but I've managed to steal your Gmail
credentials by just doing something
which is very simple watching if there
is no thing happening on your machine
and when you're doing something just go
see what this hands doing no neither did
I it's a very simple attack it's called
a pop under or a tab mapping attack
exceptionally simple to do just a piece
of JavaScript
and just to redirect now this is a hook
touch s most browsers will detect that
this is a bit funky so you can do a
couple of things one is you run it
through a mini fire and then an Eau
Claire and then a mini fire again and
generally that were kind of confused
because the the hash algorithm will look
a bit different but what you should be
doing is this is a very this is this is
one of the more nasty things you find
XSS in the website because when you
inject this it doesn't do the alert one
redirect pop-ups rubbish this gives you
interactive control with the clients
this rule out you to screw with their
head you can take now I joke a little
bit but this is a very effective
delivery mechanism for malware get them
to download a file get them to download
any type of information from you and all
of a sudden I can do things and this is
a quick delivery mechanism this way ad
networks are very dangerous because if
they get drive-by downloads where
someone just managed to just inject
something onto you then your machine is
compromised and you don't even know
about it do you know it costs two
thousand dollars for a reverse
engineering toolkit to be able to take
out the blue light in a blue light in a
driver for a web cam two thousand
dollars is what it costs you literally
open up the DLL you go in you say if on
light equals on you just go you just
comment out that line or just say if 1
equals one or whatever and ignores that
command so the light never pops on you
deliver this as a here's an update for
your webcam people download it and I
could access your webcam now we have
known there's been a massive space of
this with the kind of hoses Blackshades
malware which was using for remote
control and spying on people I think
they showed it also in mr. robot for
example just an example of doing this if
you haven't watched mr. robot is a very
good it's a fairly decent accurate
portrayal of a lot of the hacking
techniques but what is made it very very
difficult is that this also leads to
other things which is like what I think
I know after was talking about like in
this whole dark web project are people
doing revenge porn where they're
literally doing what we're calling
sexploitation
where we will get you in a state of
undress or compromise and then send you
a request for money or we will post the
photos remember hackers in some cases
are people like me where
kind of doing this for with white hat
and trying to get you to be protected
but there's a lot of people are just
doing without the morals and ethics so
if you take away those that's the
playing field you're on so remember not
everyone is playing by the same nice
rules and morals that you are so someone
is going I can make a buck off you I
will and unfortunately it is also doing
the psyche of the psychological damage
and the psychological attacks are much
more effective than the technical ones
so I social engineering is so difficult
at times know if we do a little bit more
I'm gonna show you thing which is
diamond recognize this character venom
venom is Eddie Brock or is the major
kind of nemesis for spider-man but he's
also venom is also a an injection
technique used to inject shell code into
executables to make them into malware
and it is very difficult to use as I'm
about to demonstrate because you know
there's no point in showing you how
mouth works are showing how to write it
- and how difficult it is to to do it so
to do this you just type MSF venom first
off we're gonna set up a handler so
we're gonna say where you're gonna dial
home - so I've told that this is now a
listener okay it's a command in control
so I'm saying I'm here doing something
and just setting up a listener for me to
do things okay this is setting up so
that when my executable dials home it
knows what to do i type in MSF venom
tack I think it's F no P program windows
come on out this camp type right wait
for it
meterpreter and refers H reverse tcp in
other words when i the in type of
injection shell i want you to use is
when you get opened create a TCP socket
back to me and I'll tell you what to do
okay it's a payload delivery mechanism
and I'm gonna tell it to use the the
local host which is B so that's the name
of the machine I want to use this could
be a DNS it could be an IP address it
could be something like using dynamic
DNS for example and it's say just to
CNCs whatever and this is my my machine
here I'm going to say use the the exit
port is four four four four I could do
this out of port 80 four four three
whatever and I'm gonna say use a file
table XE and I'm gonna pipe this out to
P linked are you see okay I could do
this to flash updater dot exe for
example I can call it whatever and this
will inject shellcode
which will make it a machine now
vulnerable when I try and download
runners okay so it just is just gonna
run I'm going to go onto my Windows
machine
I'm gonna run P link it tries to tell me
something's wrong I click run anyway
because you know Windows user and and I
use Windows I do this a lot but nothing
happens
but on the back what will happen is wait
a second
whew sending stage is sending
information back because et's phoned
home
I said II T do [__] off and it tries to
do things and I'm gonna now interact
with it on a session level so this gives
me remote control of the machine so what
I want to do first is get a listen
sessions I can see that I'm running on
desktop as Nile I'm going to connect to
session three because that's the one I
have and now if I do sis info it'll tell
me I'm running on this desktop x64 build
British UK English in workgroup build
number of Windows okay so that's I know
I'm on that machine now so what I think
I should do is load a thing called a
different command control software
called espía an SP allows me to take a
screenshot of the desktop or whatever
you're running at at that time and it's
very difficult to just whole screen grab
okay wait for it
done press that and it pops up that's
what's on my desktop so that's the
remote users desktop they just clicked a
file it wins are you sure and I went yes
and now what I plan to do is like you
know I'm gonna I'm gonna go back into
Windows I hope I think if they remember
the demo come on it's still doing things
incoming so first thing I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna try and get a new local user
on the machine so I'm gonna gain local
access because remote access is always
handy if you can gain more access to the
machines and keep it up and running so I
can see here right now that I have an
NBC demo now demo there's nothing on the
machine there's only one person that's
me okay I own the box I'm gonna go back
in here I'm gonna do a thing called get
system I'm gonna elevate myself to
system administrator Don get system
finished I
I'm going to add a new local user
because we need a local user on a
machine to do things and as the tech
days NL password one two three four
exclamation mark super secure
it's out of the new user however the new
years doesn't really have permissions so
we might add them to the local user
group of administrators because who
doesn't like being an administrator
rusev root group right do that very very
simple I go back into Windows you have a
notice anything I clicked I've just gone
over go back again and now I have a new
administrator user so I have a local
administrator user you wanna know if
someone's infected your network if
you've got a machine that goes up and
down like a trampoline like a dog on a
trampoline okay and it suddenly stops
and it works somebody fixed it somebody
fixed it for a reason
because they were going this is handy to
have I wish it had me walking down okay
it's like going home at Christmas and
dad says can you fix my email you go
sure and you fix it and it works that's
what people do and that's that's how you
detect a hacker there's an anomaly you
know and you find out there's something
wrong so here's what we're going to just
rob a bank instead because one of the
things I like showing people is how we
are going to attack using if I'm on the
same network as you and we're gonna try
and steal credentials from you now the
thing is before I start the bank is not
vulnerable the bank in itself is not
vulnerable what I am take the advantage
of is a number of different techniques
and there's a very narrow margin right
now and it doesn't really work since
about new versions of Chrome have popped
up in new versions of ie but what we're
going to do is we're going to take
advantage of B being under the on the
same network as you and then routing
your traffic and screwing with it and by
that we're going to rob sir I don't know
so first off I think I'm going to run a
thing is I'm going to show you what an
ARP table looks like an ARP table is the
command eight is the connection between
the MAC address in the IP address in
other words the visiting address and the
sender's address and you can see here my
gateway is going out of 60 and I have
another computer that has a d4 - t2 so
in other words that's my attack box a
1-run is a thing called not in the
middle framework from bite leader and
this is going to an ARP spoof so I'm
going to change where your gateway it's
now become your gateway and I can
intercept your traffic I'm also going to
run in a reverse DNS and a hey chess TS
bypass so it's a couple of different
techniques and technologies put together
so
we distribute is off a network or a
particular connection you can see here
now that without any check any
notifications the user that my gateway
has changed to DT 4 - t2 which is the
same as my attack box so at this point I
can now intercept information from you
and I can change it on the fly so I'm
gonna go to ee w serrano all right
I'm not as live internet traffic there
is nothing screwed with that except the
problem is Nile has been drinking and
doesn't know how to use a computer so it
takes me a little bit of time to get the
magnifier working and I'm short for time
and I like telling this joke bubbles to
scooch forward to it and will get us
there we go so we now have w w w w
certain know we're gone from the World
Wide Web to the weird world wide web
kids right this should be still playing
and when I scooch over to the login page
okay I can go to net bank and I'm still
over HTTP
meaning I'm now over plaintext meaning I
can sniff what you're doing right so if
I do this and I lock because the reason
I picked this particular Bank is they've
got a great thing login without bank ID
which is awesome because I can put any
user name and password and if I just I'm
just little but I for a time when it's
gonna skip forward a bit and it just
does things but I can find here
there's my username and password
from a bank now I can do the exact same
thing with Google so if I go to
google.com and we all know now you can
see how all this is because it's Chris
really dies this is January 2016 Sonya
the idea here is that we don't lie to
Google everything we type into Google it
remembers right so when I go to
www.google.com this this demo and if I
skip forward a little bit and I click on
to sign in my very wide screen I also
can see up here that has gone to account
Google da da no also on HTTP meaning
icons now sniff your password and your
Google Account gives me access to a ton
of information because it's an
authentication provider so if you don't
how many people don't up to FA on Google
or Facebook or Twitter I love being a
security audit you don't do you wanna
come up here and do the test in it so
here as you can see I can just get the
password out of Google very very quickly
all right now one final demo before I go
this is a very simple one but we always
say that remote our local access trumps
everything so I'm going to show you how
to hack a Windows machine which is very
much this so what I'm going to do here
is show you my dev box at home which is
secured by me almost it doesn't have
BitLocker running out but here you can
see that it does have my stuff I
apologize for the flashing you know it's
very hard to screen recording when
you're trying to this and what I'm
basically gonna do is reboot the machine
using a tool called canvas which allows
me to change the memory as it's loaded
just this really cool hacker effect it's
the old style Commodore 64 loading
screen I think right and what it allow
me to do is when the machine boots in
allowing me to create a new local user
does everyone know the sticky keys
bypass for Windows excellent
sticky keys bypass for Windows is
awesome but this allows me to do it
without having to do a regenerative
recovery cd and what I want to do is add
a new net user me for demo I'm gonna add
it as an administrator and then on
reboot machine which gives me local
admin rights on a machine with
having to show I was ever there a crack
your password which is really cool
because you've ever trying to bypass
someone's logins it's really really hard
so what I'm going to try and do is here
I'm just gonna add just a new
administrator user groups okay done I'm
gonna plug out the other thing I'm
rebooted so I've got nothing there you
can see I've only got three users on the
side alright I unplug this and my
machine is so fast when I reboot
don't screw you Mack so I now have a
demo user and if I put in the password
that goes with us password one two three
four it goes windows goes hi
I'm happy you're here I missed you
it's actually does it's really nice
windows is very pleasant to me it
actually comes up and as a administrator
now the funny thing is this also works
for Mac so if you have a Mac that you
can bypass or can't connect to convert
works for the Mac it is hugely expensive
is $19.90 everything fought to but the
defense against this fire app as a file
vault on went on on Mac and BitLocker on
Windows or someone drive encryption now
I have just gone through a number of
different hacking your neighbor
strategies and some life skills I'm
going to open up to the floor actually
one fun story just before I'm here um
Patricia do you remember when we had a
discussion long time back the demo I
just showed you was how we would hack
yeah so Patricia and I had a very fun
conversation on please would you stand
up and I gave her Patricia a round of
applause she fixed the voting problem we
were having I think she deserves for her
absolute crazy work she's a huge round
of applause if you don't know why she
stopped us being screwed by our people
doing vote counting problems and because
we had a discussion and I said this is
how I would do it by just getting on the
same network as you and I showed you the
Recon techniques I would have done by
getting in there and she kind of took at
my words and said I can make it better
and tell people in Norwegian now a thank
you I'm but she also put her a very
creative spin on that do you think you
were underappreciated at the time so
welcome any questions
three two one go get coffee thank you so
much by the way please vote if you like
the talk give it a green if you didn't
like the talk come talk to me